I do have to talk Outer Banks quickly
with you because the last time I
interviewed you people were very upset
that I did not ask about Kiara and
jayjay and there's a lot of shippers
asking it now there we are we are what
you say to the people who want to see
Kiara and jayjay together um first and
foremost congratulations on creating
your entire entity of a ship you you've
seen all the posts on social media
though right like people got Rudy
calling right now
Mariah's mom I a second thing I would
say is Madison and Kiara and with let's
keep the shifts on the show um but as
far as the show I'm all for it come on
for it be a great team partner I love
working with Rudy if that's where the
show goes it's where it goes oh you're
gonna throw a lot of fans into big tizzy
over this how has social media I mean we
sort of talked about it but how is how
have fans in general been this past week
of learning about you and being
accepting what's that been like yeah I
mean I've had I've had a lot of people
on follow me
no hard feelings no literally I do I
care at all I know my goodness one it
was I'm just like a 20/20 right people
have so much like hate I don't get it
ignorant it's fine they'll get there I
love that you're seemingly unaffected by
it
yeah are you really unaffected or like
does it hurt a little bit
I think I'm genuinely unaffected
yeah this is me and yeah we'd read
elsewhere yeah I really don't care you
know getting a lot of comments with me
MRI it's mostly just like what about
Rudy right they are they really are
having trouble like differentiate like
yeah for sure but I mean neither I nor
Mariah is bothered I would say Mariah's
less bother than I am and I don't even
care like neither of us we're good yeah
what is Rudy make of all of this but now
that he's pretty is like I mean if
having the show having the shows like it
has nothing to do with us I mean yeah is
it making you wary to like read the
comment section more no now you'll start
reading your stuff yeah for sure
there's so much positivity I had really
great fans because I know that the fans
that are still there and the fans that
are in communication with me are people
who are very accepting and kind loving
people yeah that's I would rather do
that than worry about losing followers
of like really people you know yeah sure
I think that's the best outlook that you
can have speaking of couples though
Maddie and chase officially out there
what do you make of that are you happy
for them I am happy for them that would
be a very hard thing to hide for a while
you know good for them they did it at
their own pace and I know that both of
them are extremely happy and yeah and
that's what matters absolutely yes do
you have any updates on season two is
that way back in LA no we don't have
updates on stress I'm not I know I feel
real
about its ease into it I know it's just
a matter of figuring out everything with
the virus and working through that but
yeah there a chance that we could see
you sing in season two because I had no
idea that you have the voice of an angel
but you do I'd sing a little bit um I
don't really know when it would come up
uh-huh it happens that's fine I just
can't think of an organic moment where
Outer Banks would turn into a semi
musical like a musical episode yeah
when like do you want to pursue singing
more that's something that you would be
interested in absolutely interested in
don't think it's something I'm very
unfamiliar with time will tell before I
let you go is there anything that you
want your fans to know right now whether
it's about what's going on in the world
whether it's about you we're still in
hard times and it's just gone from like
talking about one hard time to the next
hard time to everything piling up and
it's like now everything stacked on top
of each other it's like it's Pride Month
we're quarantined
it's Juneteenth right now we should
celebrate but black lives matter
everything is just heavy on top of heavy
on top of heavy so the message that I
have can started with I will continue
with and amplify take care of yourself
be selfish please take care of yourself
you know it's not an easy time and
things are really heavy and it can feel
difficult to find light and just make
sure you're finding that or looking for
that and
you know you're loved you're cared for
[Music]